speak for the ethical issues of
conducting HIV vaccine trials in
developing countries and how we actually
practically implemented these principles
in clinical research that we did in
India and in countries across Africa so
I was responsible for the you know the
first day of eight vaccine trials that
we conducted in India under I avi and
multi-country trials that we conductor
in Africa so let's be clear that ethics
is the very big picture of ethics
questions questions are you know ethics
addresses questions about morality
concepts like good and evil right and
wrong justice autonomy beneficence as
Jamie Moore said goodness the unique and
indefinable quality we should of course
always be ethical but it's probably
especially more you know when we are
dealing with people who are wonderful or
dependent on us because our not being
ethical is going to have a direct impact
on them so ethics is about honesty
truthfulness fairness and not about
methods of protocol ratification so
there's a current status core of
inherently ethical with the AIDS
epidemic we're dealing with staggering
losses of life a falling suffering God
crippling a society actually destruction
of the host you know you think families
are destroyed and so it's not only
affecting the people themselves were
infected but the whole families
communities are being infected and we've
got millions of orphans a worsening of
gender-based iniquities and inequalities
the current interventions are not
sustainable we know that for every one
person we put on treatment we need you
know form of people get infected and by
2015 the ard cost for developing
countries alone are projected at 49
billion per year and universal excess is
estimated to cost fifty four billion per
year and for developing countries like
you know across Africa and India these
these figures are completely
unsustainable so it cannot be ethical to
maintain the status quo a good HIV
vaccine has elements of a moral
imperative because even a small
reduction transmission can have a large
impact
the epidemic of the whole vaccination
against HIV could protect those who
cannot protect themselves example women
we often see women in who are married
across developing countries in Africa
and India they can't ask their husbands
to use condoms they often get infected
from their husbands and they don't have
the bargaining power they don't have the
financial economic bargaining power to
be able to demand that they can protect
themselves you know wonderful community
is like transgenders or men who have sex
with men as well as those who will not
protect themselves example intravenous
drug users vaccination awards a great
deal of human suffering and we know that
the only historically proven tool to
environ epidemics our vaccines HIV
vaccine would obviously be a long term
to fight the epidemic as part of a
comprehensive prevented package so it
would never be used alone it would be
used along with other preventive
modalities and their trials in Thailand
you know the HIV vaccine trials in
Thailand which were the results came out
recently has shown that a HIV vaccine as
possible for the first time we actually
found that you know a waxing of the two
vaccines given in a prime boost regimen
and we found that they were actually
efficacious so now we just have to
improve the effectiveness of the vaccine
but up till now we didn't know you know
there was a lot of skeptics who said
there were HIV vaccine every possible
and now we know that it is possible and
it's going to be there in our lifetime
definitely and the impact of HIV vaccine
regardless of whether you know this
vaccine would have a low medium or high
impact the number of new infections
prevented would be significant so it's
not necessary again that you know we
wait for this idle vaccine with ninety
percent efficacy regardless of you know
the first generation vaccine probably
will have a low impact but the number of
life that it will new infections
prevented in the number of life saved
would be significant
but we have to gather with the ethics of
trials because vaccines and drugs have
to be tested in clinical trials because
they're no good animal models especially
for HIV infections clinical trials are
from shore unexpected results and trials
and industrialized countries are not
always a good guy a guide to developing
countries for example testing a subtype
b vaccine in a developed country we you
know I've been involved in trials across
Europe and the US with a subtype b
vaccine you cannot extrapolate those
results to a subtype c you know in india
of example india and south africa the
predominant strain is subtype c so you
cannot say that you know the subtype we
b vaccine works well in the developed
world so you can't extrapolate those
results and say the subtype b vaccine
would be able to work in developing
countries so you have to conduct the
trials with vaccines which are against
the subtype which are prevented you know
in the in the region that you're working
in and trial results in one group might
not apply to all groups for example a
vaccine that is effective in you know
men who have sex with men where the main
route of transmission is sexual might
not have the same impact in intravenous
drug users HIV vaccine trials are
sometimes controversial because they
involve healthy people in phase 1 trials
and in phase 3 trial we are working with
people at high risk for HIV infection
and these populations are nearly always
very vulnerable and very stigmatized
we're talking about populations like
transgenders men you have sex with men
intravenous drug users and the
developing world these populations are
hugely discrimination and stigma against
HIV vaccine trials are very technically
difficult are you in you actually
talking about intimate behavior social
norms and these are always very
controversial topics especially in
really conservative societies like you
find in India so they these trials
always would require a high level of
social environment permission and a
thought about the ethics of conducting
these trials now just to give you some
background on the ethical issues that
you know we constantly Gathol with when
we were conducting these trials there is
a history of mistrust for clinical
research and a history of unethical
research in developing countries so in
India for example there's a there was
unethical research which was conducted
with contraceptives with you know drugs
you know and this is when we talking
about unethical this was hugely
unethical you know volunteers did not
know what they were being given there
there was no informed consent so we do
have a history of unethical sir so that
permeates still and you know you find
that the mistress for clinical research
this of course a stigma associated with
hiv/aids the important role of the
community and vaccine preparedness
activities when we started the
preparations for these trials we were
told that we you know volunteers will
not come forward in the Asian and
African cultural context you know people
will be very scared of participating
these trials they would just not want to
come forward our biggest fear whether
these these are no and faith and trials
you using hell you know healthy adult
volunteers for these trials and our
biggest fear was that they might be
stigmatized or discriminated against you
know people might think that they are
high risk for infection and these are
people coming forward purely for
altruistic reasons so you know we wanted
to really ensure that they came to no
harm because of the participation in
these trials need to protect the right
and well-being of animal populations you
know even the average person in Africa
India they do not have access to medical
insurance if you know god forbid if they
come to any harm because of the
participation of the trials they would
not have no access to legal recourse I
mean they would you know unless we put
in these systems in place those people
actually would suffer from a great deal
of harm because of their partners you
know put suffer from harm because of the
participation in the trials there was a
lack of freedom of women to make
automatic decisions due to social
cultural or economic constraints and you
know again we were told that women would
never come forward to participate in
these trials because they were not free
to make their own decisions and you know
and we actually had to actively address
this you know we did a lot of gender
sensitization training for ourselves we
actually put measures you know to
address the needs of women and they sure
you know which they often would bring
along when they came to participate in
these trials and we and we found that we
had equal number of men and women
participating in these trials which was
often not even the case in US or Europe
so it just goes to show that you know we
started with this whole list of thing
that everybody said you know this just
cannot be done and if you put your mind
to it and you work on it I mean it is
possible to achieve things which you
know and you know go against the social
norms there's inadequate community and
cultural experience with our
understanding of scientific research and
in such informal experience or capacity
to conduct ethical scientific review of
proposed research so we actually when we
went into the country and we had
discussions with the regulatory and
ethical bodies I still remember the
first time I went to meet the regulatory
body in the country we were told that
you know there's just no way these
trials can be conducted in India because
there was no precedent for conducting
these trials none other you know
everybody knew that these trials were
going to get a lot of media attention so
the regulatory netiquette bodies and all
said they did not want to put themselves
on the line and they do not have the
expertise they said very clearly we
don't have the expertise of you know we
don't know anything about these vaccines
we don't want to put ourselves in the
line by allowing these trials be
conducted so we actually had to work
very closely with the scientific and
ethical bodies developer actual approval
pathway for these trials and you know
actually build up their knowledge so
that they became competent to provide
scientific and ethical review and and
other organizations after us try this
but you know others probably the only
organization to date which has got
permission to conduct these phase one
trial normal phase 1 trials in the
country and that's just because of you
know all the background educational and
work that we put in and you know working
with the scientific and regulatory
bodies to get them to understand what it
was we trying to do try at capacity and
country scientific capacity development
for the seneschal we were very clear
that you know any research that we would
mean the country had to be done to
international standards but we do not
even have the dissenters you know we do
not have that
the lab we do not have immunology of
biology labs or you know data management
centers or clinical centers to
physically conduct the trials and it was
a essential to manage the expectations
of the community media and politicians
for example if a politician makes one
draw in a one statement against a trial
this has a potential to completely bring
that trial to a halt in developing
countries so we actually had to you know
work with the last stakeholder to
educate them and you know make them
understand the ethics of the trial that
we were trying to do understand you will
get their buy-in before we could conduct
these trials in the country so the core
principles of research in developing
countries which I personally have always
followed is you know when you're working
with the community you need to develop
safe effective and affordable vaccines
against the subtypes of HIV prevalence
in the developing world so we actually
developed subtype c vaccines subtype c
was the predominant strain prevalent in
india and south africa and tested them
in these country then you know similarly
in the other countries that we worked in
across africa you were actually making
sure that the subtype matched with the
predominant strain prevent the
developing country and you know for
example the HPV vaccine there's a lot of
media controversy currently in the US
about that vaccine here's a vaccine for
three hundred dollars how many people in
the developing world can afford to have
access to its vaccine so you know you
have to have safe and effective but also
affordable vaccine so that actually
reach of the populations are required
and we made sure that we put in measures
to ensure this up front again fairness
you know it's the ethical principle of
fairness that community little search is
conducted need to have a realistic
prospect of rapid access to the vaccine
of it works it's just not ethical that
you know you have researchers dive into
a country conductor research take the
learnings out and then you know that
community where the research is
conducted does not benefit from that
research does not ever have access to
their vaccine you know that vaccine
might come to those that country 10 or
15 years late and then it still might be
at an unaffordable price so
that at the end of the day is completely
unethical you need to request the
consent involvement of affected
communities conduct research in an
ethical transparent manner which is fed
back to the community and it's it's very
imperative that we've been tangent but a
tangible benefits to the communities and
countries that host a research so you
know you need to strengthen the
expertise the capacity says the systems
the infrastructure of the healthcare
systems in these countries will be
conducting research because I mean what
is the you could you could always you
know go into a country not help them
develop any of the capacity conductor
surgeon or get a team of four
investigators to go into a country
conducts research and then take the
results and go out how does the country
or the communities benefit from that and
that at the end of the day is completely
unethical and when we're dealing with
the individuals so all dealings with
volunteers had to be marked by respect
for the inherent dignity of every human
being they had to be honestly about the
possible risks and benefits and here
keep in mind that often we were dealing
with populations in these countries who
had low levels of literacy you know if
they did not even have basic
understandings sometimes about hiv/aids
you know so we literally vast art you've
scratched starting with explaining what
hiv/aids was explaining what vaccines
were how back how in a potential AIDS
vaccine work and then going on to
explain the details of other trial and
you know they had to be knowledgeable
about the recent benefits so it's we're
dealing with populations who do not have
a very high level of literacy but that
the not take away from the ethical
imperative to make sure that they
understand the risks and benefits and
can make her informed consent they had
to be a transparency about trial conduct
an agreement about how sensitive data
would be handled and protected like I
said our biggest fear was that these
volunteers might come to some harm that
their personal data would be taken by
the media and splashed about the media
would be very happy to you know run a
story that you know see this is a
volunteer who's participating in the
trial but that volunteer then could come
to a lot of you know I'll come under get
involved in a media circus and come to a
lot of you know social and harm for
example they might suffer from your
people might think that they are
infection that's why they're
participating this trial so you know we
actually had to make sure that the data
was kept completely confidential and
there is no potential of their data
being leaked out full information about
KH be offered and safeguards had to be
made available and they had to be a
absence of coercion or unfair newsmen so
and we had to combine this with a
realistic estimate of you know the
choice of this poor and vulnerable
populations often have to make so for
example we could not offer an amount for
reimbursement which was very large you
know you wanted people to come forward
for purely altruistic reasons if you
were offering a very large amount as
reimbursement for participating these
trials in these poor communities you
know people might come forward for the
money itself and that of course would
not be ethical that would be unfair and
you smell and understanding of all the
above that we'd most credit through in
independent verification so is very well
to say okay we're going to put in places
ethicals you know ethical measures in
our trials but at the end of the day you
actually have to demonstrate that you
you've done that so it's not only in the
theory demonstrated in the practice by
audits and monitoring being conducted
so these were some of the research
centers that we conducted are conducting
these clinical trials Uganda Rwanda
zambia south africa kenya and india so
there are two centers in india poonen
chennai and this was done by the
international eight vaccine initiative
so I was the medical director
responsible for the trials conducted in
india and the multi-country trials
across africa so like I said it's
ethical imperative to to be doing look
capacity building in the US in the
countries where you're working in you
need to leave the country the community
is better off in terms of infrastructure
personnel technical capacity development
and provide the best possible care and
treatment to trial volunteers and again
I don't think it's it's an ethical
argument that says that you know if you
are doing research in a developing
country the standards of research can be
lower than in the developed world
because you know even that's an that's
not ethical and even from a scientific
perspective you know if you're doing
research to a lower standard your data
is never going to be accepted by the
international regulatory authorities so
then there's no sense in your having
conducted this research so for all these
trials it's not only ethics would not
only make sense from a moral perspective
but also it makes good scientific sense
so these vaccine trial centers were
actually standardized so we had the same
standard of these centers across Europe
the US and Africa and Asia we've had the
same equipment staff training same
external quality assurance staff was
extensively trained again as per the
capacity building of the of the star
team that we're working with
infrastructure was literally we put you
know infrastructure into place we were
working in centers which often did not
have you know even the basic instruction
there we set up you know clinical Center
safety monte biology laboratories data
management centers and to make sure that
the wallet is got the best possible care
and treatment we set up reliable medical
reference systems trial monitoring off
of the wall tree counseling and testing
Risk Reduction counseling so it's you
know and these are measures which were
directly going to benefit the volunteers
and benefits
communities you know because they could
be the center now are being used for
other research has been conducted in the
country these supporting services that
we set up i mean we train the staff you
know you offer them international
national level training train them to
the highest levels and now they are able
to offer these services even to the
other population which accepts these
centers so it's you know it's not only
it it's not only that this these
measures that we put in place help help
the vaccine research but it also helped
the general community and it's still
continuing to do so we actually prepared
informed consent documents which were
prepared with expert group so we got
together ethicist scientists you know
policymakers people affected with HIV
you know to come and give their inputs
into the informed consent documents that
we culture and gender sensitive easy to
comprehend ethically sound standard
reimbursement is offered so that it
would not serve as an inducement
measures had we put in place to ensure
volunteers confidentiality so we
actually had very clear-cut language
that you know what happens what are the
measures that we put in place to ensure
the volunteers confidentiality and you
know what are the ramifications on the
trial team if the volunteers
confidentiality was you know broken for
example so that was something we were
just not prepared you know that these
volunteer should come to any harm
because of the participation in the
trial all these informed consent for
translated into the partisans regional
language so that again because you're
working across so many you know regions
and countries so we had to have this
information translated into the regional
language the one it is again like I said
because we were working with populations
who might not have a high literacy rate
so again they had to demonstrate it you
know we had a test of understanding they
had to score high on these tests of
understanding before they could you know
participate in these trials so we
actually needed to make sure that they
understood all the ramifications of you
know they're participating in these
trials and these templates now you know
they've been adapted for use by other
clinical researchers in the country so
the idea is you know just to put in
place
ethical measures and then make sure that
you know they're distributed as widely
as possible across the countries we
emphasized the need to obtain informed
consent from each individual person
rather than from their family members or
community elders and confidentiality you
know we we could not discuss the warrant
is participation with their spouses
family members or friends and the
decision actually had to be left to the
volunteers there's an interesting story
here you know two of the investigators
from the centers in india you know they
thought they were being highly ethical
but the biggest fear was that you know
if our volunteers paos found out they
were participating in a trial later on
they might put pressure on the volunteer
and you're the volunteer would drop out
of the trials so they didn't want
volunteers to drop out of trials so
there they came up the suggestion that
you know the information about the
volunteers participation you know must
be discussed with their spouses and
family members and they had to be buying
from the spouses or family members
before these volunteers could
participate in the trials so yeah you
know we held a lot of discussions with
these investigators and you know finally
convinced them that at the end of the
day it has to be a decision that the
volunteer takes whether you know their
information while they're participating
the trials is shared with their family
members it could not be a decision that
the investigators took on the wall until
behalf because that would have been
completely unethical now to ensure that
the trial volunteers receive the best
possible care and treatment for the
disease condition during the trial of a
possible HIV infection you know these
volunteers could get infected from HIV
due to their actress behavior while they
were participating the trials territory
different guidelines for volunteers are
formulated through a national
consultation we actually got scientists
community-based organization members
NGOs people living with HIV government
partners ethicists around the table we
got an expert from Brazil South Africa
Kenya to come and share their
experiences and we it wasn't an easy
task to actually formulate these care
and treatment guidelines because you
know you you you have to make sure that
the volunteers we see the best possible
care and treatment but
same time it had to be practically
implementable is no sense in having
really guidelines which are not
practically implementable and you're
just having them on paper and not having
them in not having the wall enters
receive the best possible care and
treatment and you cannot again set up
systems in a country which are again not
sustainable so took us a lot of time and
a lot of discussions you know to
actually come to consensus and prepare
these care and treatment guidelines
arbitration boards are set up for the
first time for these trials medical
insurance was offered to volunteers for
the first time in the country for the
duration of trials and you know this it
these guidelines and fine systems were
considered as gold standards in the
country by the Government of India and
these guidelines were actually
implemented in trials in Africa and
India and now the interesting you know
so I still remember there was a national
level meeting where the Government of
India invited me to share these
guidelines with you know and they were
representatives of other pharma
companies who were there and you know
because these were considered gold
standard so you know they wanted us to
share these guidelines and the feedback
that we got from these pharma company
representatives who were actually
conducting trials of the country whether
this is you know all very well but they
you know they were not really interested
in putting together such measures and
you know we provided them with the data
that it was actually the the
cost-benefit analysis that hitter or it
wasn't very expensive and it were very
practically feasible and their reaction
was you know this is very nice but we
are not interested in it and now
recently the government of india is
actually put together a policy in place
where they're going to make it mandatory
for all these measures to be implemented
in the country so it's you know it's a
very slow process not chain does not
happen overnight but you know if you
keep working at it it is possible to
make changes and you know make things
ethically better and you know those
those companies those pharma companies
actually had that option you know they
did not we had done all the groundwork
for them we had put together the
measures they just had to take what we
had done and implemented in their trials
and they could have got a lot of mileage
out of it they could have you know help
themselves actually done more ethical
trial but that at that point of time do
not did not think that ethics for the
big enough issue or they do not think
that this was something that they wanted
to focus their attention on yeah neither
i think because they be recorded so we
can just take questions at the end and
in terms of community outreach they had
p widespread dissemination of
information on clinical research to
build support for the trials to reassure
potential volunteers to ensure
transparency but trial conduct and the
communities had to be involved in the
design implementation and distribution
of the research results so we actually
engage the civil society as partners for
our HIV vaccine program we had open door
meetings in the high prevalence states
where anyone could walk in and we
literally you know ask any question that
they wanted and we literally walked them
through you know hiv/aids vaccines AIDS
vaccine the science behind it what it
was that you're trying to accomplish in
these trials we consulted an interactive
with NGOs community-based organizations
women's organizations policymakers donor
groups the media are positive people's
groups lawyers activists and religious
leaders and just to give you an example
when we initially started the
preparatory work in the country a lot of
the NGO leaders you know they were
really against the work you know they
thought that we were using that the
populations as guinea pigs and the
father population might come to harm and
we actually did a lot of work with them
explain what it was we were trying to do
explain the science of what we were
trying to do plain the ethical measures
were taking and later on some of these
activists actually turned out to be our
biggest supporters you know they were so
against ours in the beginning and then
later they were willing to put their
reputation online write articles talk to
the media supporting the research that
was being done so it just it's it
doesn't happen overnight but it's very
important to take the community along
with you we disseminated information on
the advancing program and the science of
vaccines through the newsletter through
the website info gates and frequently
asked questions prepared on HIV HIV aids
aids vaccine trial organizers and they
were translated into
local regional languages in the
different country that we were working
in we again worked with the policy
makers including the president of the
country Prime Minister leader of the
Opposition and chief ministers of the
high prevalence states across Africa and
India that we were working in you know
we held our policy workshops 11
consultations and regular briefing that
both the national and regional level
again just to keep them informed about
the work that we were trying to do and
get their buy-in and get their
understanding for the work that we're
trying to do now the media this was
really a you know and there were a lot
of challenges but this was probably
right up there with often we find that
in developing countries you know the
media is the media reporters but not
even be you know scientifically trained
they often do not have a lot of good
idea about you know the and they often
don't you know take the effort to
confirm facts to rather have a
sensational story which has their papers
sell and so we literally was starting
from scratch to understand with the
media folks to and to make them
understand the science of vaccines the
complexities and issues about the
clinical trials we had intensive media
briefings one-on-one meetings with
journalists and editors and initially
there was a lot of favorable media
coverage and community response to
trials but at the end of the first phase
one trial that we conducted in India
there's one reporter who you know he
didn't even have a basic understanding
about the phases of trials at the end
points of what it was that you're trying
to accomplish and he just wrote a orbit
story without you know any scientific
facts but it was such a sensational
story it was picked up and he has whole
media circus erupted and it was you know
it was really a lot of effort and to you
know address the media queries to help
address the inaccurate media reports
that were coming out and make sure that
what was printed actually was signed for
correct so this led to increase caution
regarding media coverage among the
partners but in this also emphasized the
importance of media activist advocacy
briefing prompt response to the queries
a close interaction between global and
regional communication teams and they
actually
these lessons for future communications
and we had favorable media coverage for
other trials that we conducted in Africa
and India so this is just to show you
that you know you might say that you you
want to do good you know because it's
the ethical imperative or something but
it's just not necessary that is going to
be a cakewalk I mean it's it's often
very difficult to practically implement
the theory but it's it's Nestle at the
end of the day it was necessary to have
community participation at all levels of
the program so we had a national
advisory board national consultation of
care and treatment a gender advisory
group NGO working group informed consent
group management advisory board this
suggests you have buy-in from different
stakeholders and different sections
society and actually make the community
understand you know what it was that we
were trying to do these groups had a
major advisory role at the initial stage
of the program and there was no prior
precedent for setting up such groups but
we know big fence that it was epicly
very important to do so and a lesson
learned was that you know clear terms of
reference and Eurasian involvement of
these members should be laid out when
you create these groups again like I
said we did constant advocacy with
government partners Public Health
Authority key opinion leaders NGOs
community-based organizations to explain
the constant advocacy in order to
explain the complex science of the
vaccine that we were trying to work on
and easily we share the learnings in an
international consultations across
Africa Asia Brazil China in meeting the
of nine by the government to indian
national international conferences and
it was very important that you know
other groups were working globally did
not have to reinvent the wheel you know
we could possibly share some of the
learnings of the work that we had done
because I firmly believe that no one
country or one organization is going to
be able to tackle this pandemic or you
know develop these vaccines it's going
to require close collaboration between
the north and south of south and south
countries now in terms of capacity
building when we actually started the
work in the country like I said we
really gotta push back from the
regulatory authorities and the ethics
committee saying that there's no prior
precedent for these trials they do not
they would not give approval for these
trials
and so you know spend a lot of time
explaining the complex science in golden
whelping vaccines to the national and
scientific experts the clinical research
team the regulatory and ethics
committees we literally started there
from scratch and you know these are
ethics committee members who are often
in the late 60s and 70s have no idea
about the global research that's being
happy you know going on around the world
you literally SAT them down from scratch
and no walk them through the various
details about you know AIDS vaccine and
the research that's being done globally
and you kept them updated so that they
could actually provide a valid
scientific and ethical review and at the
end of the day we did receive permission
to conduct these trials in the country
so it's it's feasible but it's it takes
a lot of hard work actually now working
with vulnerable communities just to give
you some idea you know up till very
recently homosexuality with a criminal
offense in India so you have populations
of men who have sex men and transgender
communities these are populations who
are completely stigmatized and
discriminated against you know they have
no access to any kind of housing food of
course no job no medical care they're
completely underground the cliff in
constant fear that they'll be over you
know that the busy arrested or harassed
by the police and so you know you know
but it was very important and ethical
imperative that we actually worked these
populations because these were the
populations were actually affected by
the epidemic and you took get them to
understand what it was that we were
trying to do so we had consultations
with men who have sex with men
transgender communities to understand
their concerns access to one free
counseling testing health care and
treatment services and gained acceptance
by these communities we did a lot of
formative research with these
communities to understand the social
structure their risk profile identify
the health taking part in the quality of
available services the potential
barriers and opportunities for
participating in future safe safe three
trials and you know it was quite an
eye-opener here are communities you know
members were often infected with HIV
themselves it was they knew that these
preventive vaccines would you know it
would never benefit themselves
them directly but they were still well
willing to come forward you know and
help out in this endeavor just because
they wanted to help their fellow you
know community members and these are
people you know who have nothing little
to the name and to still be able to do
you know so much humanitarianism is it
was quite unbelievable actually so you
know but the you know wonderful
community is he found that they expected
the vaccines to be available in the
image at time span and you know we found
that they had some disappointment when
the expectations are not met and excess
and retention of this community may be a
challenge for last cave clinical trials
so in conclusion you know we try to
address the ethical issues and these
trials in HIV vaccine trial that we
conducted across Africa and India we set
up normal intellectual property
agreements vaccines which would tailor
to the subtypes of HIV in the regions of
the greatest need to ensure that the
populations actually would have access
to the product you know if it if it was
found to be successful develop long-term
relationships and worked in close
coordination within the country
literally we worked from top down from
the health ministries we weren't
partnerships with the government's in a
number of countries down to the local
community the training of the staff has
provided in extensive training of course
in the scientific aspects but on the
dignity of volunteers gender
sensitization ethical conduct of trials
and actually we found you know these are
actual teams which we often had to put
in place no prior experience of clinical
research or ethics of trial but if you
give them enough training and you were
closely enough for them they did a
fantastic job in these trials we found
that we had women enrolled in these
trials you know in equal numbers and Men
which was saying that you know we look
unheard of and people had said that this
would never be possible we had to be
honest for the possible risks and
benefits so we had a complex approval
for the informed consent procedures
transparency but the trial conduct by
millions community media advocacy groups
for protecting the sensitive data we had
advice from outside security consultants
we put in the majors for providing care
in the trials and you know antiviral
antiretroviral therapy for these
volunteers in case they became infected
with participation you know they became
infected during the participation in the
trials we put in measures for real
realistic our prospects for rapid access
to the vaccine if it was found to work
so you actually had agreements that we
put in place with the governments of the
countries they were conducting the
research they had to be a flat
compensation for work miss turn expenses
incurred you know so there was no unfair
inducement test of understandings we had
to actually demonstrate the volunteers
you know understood and were actually
providing in you know consent after
understanding all the risks and benefits
so you know the test of understanding
with the high score these we had to you
know put in place laboratory methods so
distinguish between natural HIV
infection and vaccine induced sero
positivity no [ __ ] there Walters
might have a positive HIV test you know
when they receive a vaccine even though
they were not truly infected but we
wanted to make sure that these
volunteers came to no harm because of
the participation in the trial so we
actually have provided them with special
participation cards you know for these
volunteers who tested positive
antibodies to HIV because of the vaccine
and we you know these are we you know we
are it was it actually worked out very
well we did not find that you know any
of the volunteers suffered from any kind
of harm because of the participation in
these trials so ethical behavior
requires competent management you know
most trial organizers and clinicians
will try to be ethical but some fail to
deliver because it's not simple to do
what you promised and any any measures
that you put in place have to be
monitored measured quantified and
reported so not enough to say that you
know we putting these ethical measures
in place without actually you know
having monitoring of trials done and a
quantifiable a coronary no quantifiable
where is being put in place and ethical
behavior is linked to good clinical
practice you know like we discussed poor
delivery and black planning or lack of
care would lead to poor retention of
volunteers and would render our trial
useless any inducement coercion or
explain the rest buddy to dishonesty
among apart Smith and misleading data
failure to protect the confidentiality
of the volunteers you know we would have
had harm to the participants and then
the other volunteers would have left so
this would have been fatal to the trial
for gender balance again would deliver
useless results and so unethical trials
would always produce bad result so it's
not only from a moral imperative that
you have to make sure that the ethical
measures are put in place but also from
a scientific impaired measure and
reasonable people can disagree I mean
what is an adequate level of care in a
clinical trial you know excessive
provision might be unpinned you sment
inadequate provision might be
inequitable so when does a kimono when
does the amount become an inducement you
you have 17 visits in a phase one trial
and the value of a lost work day is not
the same for a lawyer and teacher so you
have to gabble with all these issues and
when the risks are improbable that it
should not be mentioned you know most
people would not even take an aspirin if
you actually read the full data sheet of
possible adverse effect but at the same
time you have to make sure that the
volunteers were had a clear
understanding of the risks and benefits
of participating in the trial and knew
what they were getting into so the
expertise of these issues but no
monopoly of wisdom and they should never
be a compromise and fundamental ethical
issues but the questions of judgement
benefit from you know consultation and
one unresolved issues remain you know we
always found it with very helpful to
highlight these two potential volunteers
so a lot of people think about the
ethical issues of conducting these
results but you know we actually had to
decide and implement them in the trials
but this is not the end you know folks
like you you know you you're constantly
working and grappling with these issues
this new thought being given to the
ethics and this is a constantly evolving
field and you know trials that are going
to be conducted you know a year or two
years from now there might be other
measures that I have put in place but
you need to constantly think about these
measures and make sure that they are
implemented for the best possible in the
trials that are conducted thank you very
much